former democratic congresswoman Tulsi
gabbard who now regularly speaks at
anti-vaccine events
seemed to shock even Fox News host Jesse
Waters when she compared affirmative
action ideas and the idea of
um I mean I don't even she compared
Biden to Hitler I don't even know how
else to say it this you have to see the
general subject matter during the former
congresswoman's interview with Jesse
Waters was Biden quote choosing
diversity over competence which by the
way there's no evidence at all that Joe
Biden has done
um and she said these are the principles
that the Nazis and Hitler embodied she
has really taken well to this new role
as an anti-woke free speech whatever
they call her at this point right their
philosophy identity politics and this is
one of the main reasons why I left the
Democratic by the way I'm sorry it
already interrupt I wonder remember tool
sees against identity politics will she
come out against the identity politics
campaign of Nikki Haley who's like I
don't really know of any reason that you
would vote for me over Trump on policy
but like I'm younger and a woman and of
Indian Heritage is she is is too because
Tulsi of course would never play
partisan games okay sorry let's take it
from the top here their philosophy
identity politics and this is one of the
main reasons why I left the Democratic
party because you're seeing how their
agenda of identity politics is directly
undermining the traditional democratic
values that were expressed so
beautifully and clearly by Dr Martin
Luther King that we should judge each
other not based on the color of our skin
but based on our character and yet as
you have displayed here over and over at
the example after example they're proud
to be judging people hiring people
selecting People based on race which is
really let's be clear how serious of a
problem this is yeah it's based on
genetics race uh based on your blood
your genes and and where do we see that
connection well these are the very same
geneticist core principles embodied by
Nazism and Adolf Hitler and this should
be something that is sickening and
alarming to every single Democrat and
everything it's sickening and alarming
to me that Tulsi would say this single
American we have seen where this uh
philosophy can lead right
noticing hey we dramatically
underrepresent for example black women
in the Judiciary maybe we could like
make them slightly less
underrepresentative next thing you know
they'll be coming to kill the Jews it's
exactly the thing this is insane now let
you all know me on this issue I don't
believe that we can even remotely have a
Judiciary that exactly matches the
American population along every
demographic line I have not heard anyone
on the left say listen
um the population is like 50.5 percent
women so 50.5 percent of all judges
should be women and white people make up
what is it now like 69 of the population
so we need 69 of the population of the
Judiciary to be white and then 12 of the
population is 55 to 64. I'm making that
number up now so 12 of the Judiciary
must be 55 to 60. nobody that I have
seen
myself included is calling for that type
of equality of outcome when it comes to
the Judiciary
what Joe Biden has identified is that
the Judiciary is already dramatically
unrepresentative of the population at
Large
so Joe Biden during his tenure so far
has nominated
disproportionately more black women to
the Judiciary that's true
and we still have a dramatic
underrepresentation of black women in
the Judiciary Joe Biden has only made it
slightly more reflective of the
population now what the right loves to
say is because of the prioritization of
identity over competency by virtue of
appointing a lot of black a lot
comparatively more black women
we are reducing the competency because
they're being chosen not for their
judicial Acumen but instead because of
their racial identity this is one of the
dumbest things that they claim when they
want to act against identity
act against
affirmative so-called affirmative action
under the guise of identity politics
this is a country of 331 million people
my guess is if you said we are going to
have a Judiciary that is 70 black women
there are enough competent black women
judges that you could do it and they
would all be competent similarly if you
said we're going to have 80 percent of
the Judiciary be Asian people oh but
isn't that going to choose racial
identity over competency we have 331
million people in this country and we
have enough competent Asian jurists that
you could do that anyway so the issue is
not that we are choosing incompetent
people based only on their race it's we
have so many competent people of all
Races in this country that if you say
well I'm going to over select a group
that has been historically under
selected you're choosing from all
competent people that's the reality and
there doesn't sound anything like Nazism
in it to me if you disagree with me let
me know did you know that every year 30
million trees are cut down to meet the
demand of toilet paper in the United
States alone here's something really
simple you can do to fight climate
change a little bit in your home our
sponsor real paper makes toilet paper
100 from bamboo stocks which keep
growing forever no trees are cut down
it's shipped right to your door in
plastic free packaging it's fluffy it's
soft like regular toilet paper you're
not making any quality sacrifice and for
every box you buy real paper donates to
reforestation efforts Across America
through their partnership with one tree
planted so instead of the toilet paper
you're currently buying which cuts down
trees and wastes plastic use real paper
actively helping the planet you can set
up a recurring subscription so you're
always stocked or do a one-time purchase
the average American uses 50 pounds of
toilet paper or more every year make the
easy switch switch to real paper you'll
get thirty percent off your first order
plus free shipping go to realpaper.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down below